[Musique]
les espagnols sont très fiers de leur
jambon séché il y a le serrano qui est
l'origine provenaient des montagnes
entendu c'est le plus populaire et le
plus vendu par tous ces sacs un produit
plus vite ce que on peut faire une
grosse quantité qu'ils soient de
fabrication artisanale ou fait à grande
échelle la base est la même c'est du
port que l'on salle et que l'on fait
sécher le serrano si la charcuterie de
tous les jours avec laquelle on fait des
sandwichs et qu'on cuisine comme nous le
démontre le chef du restaurant ibérique
hausse à montréal ici avec des choux de
bruxelles des artichauts ou encore des
moules
mais en dégustation c'est plutôt le
jambon ibérique qu on vous servira quand
tu utilises à main technique sur la race
de porc numérique c'est que tu peux
avoir une meilleure qualité
le jambon ibérique provient des ports de
race pata negra à pattes noires il est
élevé en pâturage lors de l'élaboration
du jambon ibérique
il y à la période où la pièce de viande
est recouverte de sel pendant au moins
une semaine puis le séchage qui peut
atteindre jusqu'à 4 ce qui détermine sa
qualité et sa saveur
mais pour les espagnols le nec plus
ultra c'est le jambon ibérique de
bellota le port pata negra et non
seulement en liberté et se nourrit de
pâturages naturels mais à la fin de sa
vie il mange de six à sept kilos de
glands par jour qu'on appelle en
espagnol les b you tu as ça tu es ma
seule température ambiance cinq gars qui
est beaucoup plus fonda équivalait se
promener entre et risque donc
les résultats exceptionnels sur ma
chique à oz et l'associé de est sam au
restaurant ibérique hausse il est un des
rares à pratiquer le métier de maître
cooper à montréal mais le m cooper peut
préparer une assiette en deux ou trois
minutes tandis que novice pendant 15 à
20 minutes pour y arriver les prix pour
ces gens bons espagnols varie
considérablement
pour se procurer du serrano vous devrez
débourser environ 7 dollars les sanglots
il vous en coûtera trois fois plus pour
le jambon ibérique est cinq fois plus si
vous optez pour le jambon ibérique de
bellota donc on a serrano les ibériques
aux ibériques ob liotta ok qu'est ce que
je devrais goûter comme différence entre
ces 2 par exemple
ben a vraiment la cérémonie devrait être
plus ferme de faire un petit peu plus à
l'est je veux y aller avec les doigts
c'est la meilleure façon c'est la finale
ça l'est ouais alors qu'ici on voit
quand même c'est ça c'est déjà un petit
peu plus - lui - c'est qu autre chose et
là ça s'est fait avoir
alors la finale c'est un peu noisette
plus complètement chose direction centre
ville de montréal
au restaurant iberica où l'on sert un
des jambons ibériques de bellota les
plus rares le josélito c'est ferran
adria du célèbre el bulli en espagne qui
l'a fait découvrir aux gastronomes du
monde entier aux ibériques a pour des
raisons d'efficacité on taille celui ci
en utilisant une trancheuse manuel haut
de gamme des jeux sont possiblement le
2,3 à attendre de son élan s'oppose
cependant comme en espagne au portugal
on a une à manger dans sa loge
pour la trancheuse qui est beaucoup plus
rapide on a commencé à acheter des os et
du racket des poumons
si vous permettez j'entends un petit
morceau du monde cruel
le goûter les autres à l'espérance
non non à ok donc comprenez c'est la
couleur est différent le groupe
différent quand les gens voient ce 2001
et 10 rebonds boys band du grand emprunt
mais je dois les hôtes ont enlevé ce
bras parce qu'enfin kong à 40 à 50% mort
qui tout à fait douce et cette marge
s'est érigée aux 6es postales et les
gens pensent que c'est sale et oui c'est
salé sucré seydoux plusieurs se targue
de fabriquer le meilleur jambon du monde
mais une chose est certaine le goût et
la texture du jambon ibérique en font un
produit unique